no it's the hair fall so you attended  the Met Gala and apparently there was an  odd moment with the paparazzi yeah yeah  no one was taking my picture and Wow  okay and no one was taking it was like  pictures pictures pictures and pictures  of this was like I was wearing something  nice  it's I turned around and all of a sudden  I saw Madonna was standing there and  then everyone's taking a great picture  but someone happened to snap my picture  when I first saw her and that was  unattractive Madonna that was like the  only saving grace this is the moment  Sarah Paulson noticed it was Madonna  cider on the red carpet  [Applause]  [Music]  you